muss es eigentlich deine lieblings
weihnachtsbaumkugeln farbe alle meine
freunde willkommen zurück zu micro
frieden ruhen die mieten sturm würde
wäre ich bei diesen sturm und den
barwert die slacker und macht feld wo du
nicht dein ganzes mache das weil ich bin
halt nur ein gehalt wollen das passiert
was ist passiert
das ist auch kein pvp projekt ich habe
das letzte mal aufgenommen vor einem tag
und jetzt nämlich wieder auf an diesem
tag hast eigentlich für mich vielleicht
ich hab ein bisschen blöd aber nicht so
viel jedenfalls ich habe die kleinen
iglu gebaut das häuschen hier und dann
ist dieses heute noch entstanden weil es
hat unter anderem auch schon regie und
kefir cadooz hat auch schon aufgenommen
hat aufgenommen hätten hat aufgenommen
sehr viel und ich denke das wird richtig
cool dieses projekt und es wird noch
nachricht gute start bei rumkommen ich
werde jetzt auch mal etwas produktives
machen und die höhle ist da jedenfalls
haben wir wieder ein paar fragen haben
stark von den betten hin sturm waffel
der auch dabei ist gehe ich da ja schon
alles haben
der stürmer für den bachelor auf und
haben uns gedacht unter dem hashtag
fries könnt ihr uns natürlich auch
fragen stellt ihr hashtag fries und dann
einfach alle fragen die wir dann reden
und dann rauscht um die michelle michael
müller fragt gibt es bzw gab ist bei
euch irgendwelche weihnachtstraditionen
nicht mehr werden das thema ja schon
letzte mal mit essen was glaube ich aber
so natürlich tradition hat mir nun wir
haben da echt keine großen traditionen
irgendwie also treffen oder so familien
technisch also doch klar man ist mit der
familie beisammen ich war natürlich auch
über die feiertage nach hause aber wir
sagen jetzt nicht ich verbinde halt so
tradition weihnachtstraditionen
verbindet mit dieser tatsache ja es ist
bei uns immer so dass wir erst essen
dann die geschenke auspacken dann dies
machen anders machen und bei uns ist es
halt nicht mal so dass wir sagen ja wir
machen jetzt will man ist dass man hier
auch schon viele so und man würfelt
immer und dann darf man geschenke
auspacken oder so was in die richtung
wenn wir einmal gemacht es gibt ja alles
also wir machen einfach nur so die
einzige tradition wir wirklich haben ist
dass wir sagen ja
der luca der krieg alles nein wir haben
wirklich gar keine tradition
wir haben ihn nur das einzige was er
wirklich haben ist dass wir so nach der
reihenfolge auspacken erst meine kleine
schwester dann ich an meine eltern halt
so und wir sitzen also echt aus unterm
baum weil also keine art von unserer
familie glaubt man den weihnachtsbaum
aber trotzdem den beinahe jedenfalls
das hat unsere einzige tradition
anbieten also dass er so nach und nach
die geschenke auspacken aber sonst es
gibt ja echt so alle möglichen sachen
und ich suche die ganze zeit schon kies
und finden es nicht die einzigen kindes
natürlich nicht ich kann nicht mal
sprinten kann ich mir nicht von dir ein
bisschen weizen nehmen oder so
ja ich glaub ich hatte natürlich ihren
beruf immer okay suite ich kann eure
antworten habe ja würde ich dir nur zwei
machen der totale armut irgendwie ein
essen nicht weiß auch nicht woran es
liegt ja ich weiß auch nicht was legten
frauen einfach mal schweigen und
bewundern
wir brauchen einfach mal farbe oder
sowas in die richterin also ich weiss
nicht jetzt für euch irgendeine
tradition traditionell
ein weihnachtsessen der familie das hat
jetzt das interessiert hier auch
zugehört ja das ist ja ich weiß dass ich
dir neben familie also das essen ist ist
tradition bei uns und dann müssen wir
immer an heiligabend also am 24
in die kirche gehen muss stimmt kirche
ist auch schon eine sache also wir geben
immer in die kirche aber das auch so die
sache die mit den anderen sachen mit
messen oder so wir sagen jetzt nicht
dass wir immer vorher die kirche gehen
oder sogar mehr mich alle schon
durchgemacht wir haben immer was anderes
zu essen
wir haben immer andere zeiten man wie
eine kirche gehen und alles verändert
sich ja bei uns alles weil wir da weißt
du andere familien sagen ja montags wird
nur fleisch gegessen und so und
dienstags ist der fisch tag und alles
was haben auch viele familien aber wir
haben da ich gar nichts sonst ist
relativ jolo alles kühl transcoding die
lust sondern schlicht schon mal an zu
machen aber dafür braucht man als selbst
ja den boden hinein erhöhte wohl machen
ich glaube dieses hellem eichenholz wird
da ein bisschen aber das ist nicht so
dunkel und dann ist das mit zu
weihnachten und so weiß genau was ich
weiß was ich meine was du ja genau ich
weiß wenn ich mein ich gefallen an dem
baum hier habt ihr in dem steht so ganz
frech entschuldigen sie aber die sind
schon sehr schön
jenen begehen unter den masken ja der
waffel haben wir noch eine weitere
fragen haben standen übernommen
natürlich crazy fragte sie was war
bisher dein schönstes weihnachtserlebnis
mal so eine riege rettet oder durch
gestrahlt x raid gerettet
ich weiß nicht ich habe mal an
weihnachten wirklich einen obdachlosen
zu uns eingeladen aber er kam nicht
reissl wurde in der schule gesagt
weihnachten der liebe war ich wieder
verstrahlte liest und so damit jeden
tyler soll eine ist also sollte man
deshalb immer machen damit nie jemand
alleine ist auf der straße weil das
möchte man ja nicht aber ich hab echt
ein obdachloser angesprochen ich war
acht oder so und 8 mehr kommen sprichst
du denn mal an jene nach der schule oder
so und ob er dann weihnachten uns mit
verbringen würde
und er meinte dann einfach so ja das ist
zwar nett und so aber ich sitze ja nicht
den ganzen tag sondern also der dazu
auch zur musik gespielt und so und das
sind ja meistens die leute die einfach
nur chillen und musik spielen und dann
sondern noch ein bisschen nebenher
verdienen oder so ich meinen taylor
swift ist ja glaub ich auch dadurch
bekanntgeworden dass sie auf der straße
musik gespielt hat oder so also durch
eure augen einfach
und ja ich hab noch ganz viele samen
sollte man hier irgendjemand noch mit
anpflanzen dass die farbe noch ein
bisschen größer machen ja ja
also wie gesagt ich wollte nicht alles
fahren okay ich mache das von dir das
spiel eingebaut und das gestreamt beides
okay ich werde auch mal die tage stream
und zwar muss man der sturm aber noch
etwas beibringen sich da so links
einfügen und so war es alles aber damit
auch mal ins team kommt freunde mit mir
das schönste erlebnis hatte ich halte
ich übrigens deswegen kann ich gut
schlichte frage vor dresden
du hast kein schönstes
weihnachtserlebnis wetter also ist es
immer das gleiche
immer schön ich mag ihn
also ja ok derzeit kommt die beste frage
wahrscheinlich wollte der pumpkin sie
fragt wo ist es eigentlich deine
lieblings weihnachtsbaum kugel farbe
meine lieblings weihnachtsbaum
kugelfisch genauso welches blatt fenster
weil das war also bei uns ist es
wirklich so viele schmücken weniger in
silber und gold und sonne kaka aber ich
mag das gar nicht wir haben den immer
komplett nahezu und rot geschmückt
also ich weiß nicht so rote kugeln und
so rothe wein allerdings fanden wir ganz
cool ich mache mal mein haus nach hinten
bisschen offenen feld ein paar bäume ab
also gut lass dich und lass dich ja ich
denke eigentlich dass roth die schönste
farbe zu weihnachten verbindet man mit
liebe und mit sturm waffe und wer in
unternehmen sturm waffe und so deswegen
das meer und fahre nicht verbindet man
auch mit strom wasser und ist für dich
deine lieblings christbaumkugel farbe
lieblings grund google war ich muss das
mal so vorlesen würde die frage ist
genial war weil das war google farbe
wir wollen noch zwei kugel vor beliebt
grün so nächste frage grün grün grün ja
zu weihnachten ja grüne bio alter die
bei der pasta ganz auf ihre nächste
frage ist tatsächlich eine ganz
interessante und die kommt nun von
julius und er fragt wie findest du die
erfindung vom weihnachtsmann ist ja von
cola cola und hast du früher ans
christkind / den weihnachtsmann geglaubt
ihr hang ich denke das hat jeder gemacht
damals oder also nicht direkt
meine mutter meinte der weihnachtsfeier
schließlich wird noch was erzählst du
mir mit drei oder sogar argumentiert
also ja aufgrund der tatsache dass ich
habe also gesucht
ja klar also ich hab natürlich aber zu
einem weihnachtsmann geglaubt ich weiß
nicht genau wann man mir der glaube
daran aufgehört hat aber was ich von
dieser ganzen sache halte ist so es ist
halt marketingmäßig weiß ich müsste
jetzt auch gar nicht das von coca cola
erfunden wurde
ich dachte dass wir irgendwie mit damals
mit hätte auch coca cola war man ja der
hat rot weiß an welche büro das er seine
farbe der liebe war roten farbe von cola
diese und von panik oder der sommer und
von panik unter kunden
wo sind wo sind die geilen großen bäume
die dunkeln
die sind richtig weit weg meinte kräfte
des ich mir ein paar magere gerannt
also ich bin ich bereits einmal als ich
ganz normal gezockt aber erst in der
zweiten folge weiter im eis bei xp um
davertschule bäume die wenn man ein paar
fahrten auf der e mail und wo noch ich
hab ich jetzt länger nichts mehr also
ich hab mir gerade im juni gefallen
ich habe auch gedroht sollten die
mädchen zu töten mitnehmen jeweils einer
strip meine das liebig solchen server
sachen dass es einfach siehst okay da
war jemand der graf war richtig fleißig
der den totalen schüsse aber der ist
schon der hat of screen aufgenommen
sondern jeder der dabei auf screen
aufgenommen
mit der 100 von ganz viele sachen gesamt
also tatsächlich so geformt damit er
eben diesen baum direkt machen
produktiv sein kann okay das ist das ist
krass
allerdings ist genau das was ich brauche
nee nee ich glaube immer ab oder man
zahlt ist es dass wir hatten heute schon
eine lautstarke auseinandersetzung
tatsächlich war ursprünglich stand ein
baum federers den kev einfach weg
geholzt hat sondern sein geworden als ob
die fischer wurden na ja aber das war
also es war diese auseinandersetzung ist
auch alle sind bei mir war es aber so
ich war auf dem server gegangen und auf
einmal fehlt die hälfte von meinem dach
jeder dachte auch sowas geht aldi dass
das sollte tatsächlich ließe sich damit
ja mal bisschen wer das war
deswegen stellte das ja klar machen
kinowelt grüne war ich und noch mal
damit es nicht vergesst freunde vorne
vorne hier hallo 50
ich kann ich im chat rooms kölner gut
egal und ich denke ich heute den hashtag
freezer mal zeigen nochmal präsentieren
so dann stelle ich hier noch diese
balken wieder schön ausnehmen
wahrscheinlich nicht nur mäßige
vorstellung aber ich versuche dass ich
denke ich wenn ich so tolle konkurrenz
mit sturm und auf der anderen seite dann
muss man mich auch irgendwie so ein hund
tatsächlich muss schon ein bisschen
cooler aussehen aber meinen titel
einfacher charakter sein scheint ist
tatsächlich so
die klammern weniger machen können seid
nicht allein schon müssen ja ich hab
halt noch nicht so viele dinge krieg 100
aufzunehmen oder off screen zu zocken
ich hab mir gerade erst ein bisschen
münchen geholt und ich habe zwei eier
naja ich hab zwei eier
das ist toll ja ich hab dann schauen ob
wir da wieder rausgekommen wäre mir zwei
hühner was in diesen hühnerställen für
das chaos tolles haus hat
wir sind 23 das kriegt ja nicht zwei
wieder hier raus kriegst du kannst die
hühner benennen küche ist auch richtig
schön meint habe ich mal noch ein
zweites war mein jetziges zeit so
richtig drüber steht as rom
total die bruchbude nicht meine tür eine
türe investition ich glaube die tätige
ich jetzt mal so im pavillon eine frisur
ist und so im wochenende so im
gartenpavillon ich merke ich jetzt drei
türen raus jaja das total strange
minecraft fakten mit crafter will das
auch hinter gar nichts möchte den weg zu
den verein wenden schreibt mal in chat
so nehmen ganz vielen spanischen leuten
die den hashtag benutzen fragt friede
friede grill fragt rede mal wird über
den nikolaus und oder über schulausfall
wegen schnee dann macht man lieber oder
und reden einfach über schulausfall
wegen schnee habe ich geliebt
bei uns was recht verhalten der fall bei
uns kriegen wir nur spielausfall wenn
die temperaturen nicht in irgendeinem
raum sich verändert sondern in einem
keller in dem keller bei uns in der
schule und das war so selten der fall
also das war echt ey guck mal wurde ein
fake zugesendet minecraft mega fällt man
kriegt drei türen in der 108
kraft da ok dann für den verkehr ist
ganz ruhig mit ihren mitteln volk jeden
fall dran nehmen also etwa halt wirklich
so dass wir recht selten frei hatten
aufgrund von temperaturen unter null
aber jetzt habe ich das ja auch falsch
gebaut ich vollidiot aber ich glaube das
ist natürlich geil gewesen was auch uns
richtig selten so bei euch was oft oder
oder auf see also ich hatte das bis zur
sechsten oder siebten klasse da gab es
noch die regelungen mit tatsächlicher
temperaturen danach wurde das auch in
diese kellerräume eingeführte 7 und das
ist wichtig halten dass es im keller im
sommer warm ist oder dass es im keller
im winter kalt weil unten warm anziehen
heizungs räume und so genau wo auch
immer irgendwie ein raum ohne ohne
fenster war es dann keine ahnung
millionen aller zeiten naja aber damit
will ich sagen vor ich habe recht wenig
geschafft ich glaube ich ja auch einfach
mal off screen so ein bisschen
irgendwann bin ich eben tsb mit stürmer
für so ein bisschen hier zocken und
macht event abhalten livestream
auftritts punkt tv schrägstrich crafter
könnt ihr dann folgender werde eventuell
mit sturm habe noch ein bisschen drüber
weil der stürmer fehlte so cool mit auch
dass man von dem livestream auf facebook
gehen kann und etwa q und sollen ganze
kacke das ist auf jeden fall extrem cool
dann stehst du guck mal die kamera hier
gewandert wird